Let me ask you a leading question if I can, since I introduced our students very briefly
to optimization at the JavaScript AST level.
We might replace the subtrees like x * 1 with just x if we believed that that preserve semantics.
I was wondering if you could just give me a hint without telling me any trade secrets
about higher level optimizations that are important.
What's the next step after replacing subtrees?
In our JavaScript Engine, we've recently had a great boost from type inference.
JavaScript is a very simply called untyped or dynamically type of language.
It's important not to burn the programmers with writing down type decorations like in Java.
That was never in the scope of JavaScript and rightly so,
but the underlying runtime--the just-in-time compiling JavaScript Engine
has to know the types to get very concrete and use the hardware well.
We have a very adaptive sort of online-type inference algorithm.
You can study the code and try to infer type,s and if some codes gets loaded or invalid,
it can change its mind or it can conserve what is good and throw away what was invalidated.
That's very important for performance.
There are the traditional sort of loop invariant code motion optimizations
that we're getting into more and more because before people are writing JavaScript
that looks more like C or even Fortran in the old days. We see more graphics code.
We see more numerical processing.
Thank you for taking the time to tell us about it. >>Sure. My pleasure.